The situation we want to consider next is what if we need to
do more than one broadcast? So let's say we have this situation. You know,
we have some instructions renamed, there is the register file here.
We have some reservation stations. But, the situation is that somehow this
divide here has finished in the multiply divide unit,
at the same cycle when the add here has finished in the add unit and
now we, if we have only one of these broadcast buses that we can use to
broadcast the result, the question is, which one of these goes first?
There are first of all, several possibilities for how to support this impasse.
For example, you could have a separate broadcast bus for each of the units. So,
normally you have one of these buses. If you have a separate bus,
note that there will be twice as many comparators basically for
each of the operands for each of the instructions in the reservation stations.
We need to try to match each of the tags that are being broadcast and
be able to select the result or not depending on whether it matches.
So there will be twice as much matching hardware if we had two buses.
Similarly here and here you will have to be able to write the results and so on.
So if you have only one bus then the question is, which one do we broadcast. And
usually, you either just make one unit be the highest priority unit and
the other ones are kind of less priority than that so that you always know.
I mean, you, we, we need to choose very quickly which one is going to
be broadcast. It doesn't matter so much which one it is as much as it
matters that it's only one. So basically, one of them needs to be picked.
A very common heuristic is that if one of the units is known to be
slower than the other, let's say that the multiplication and
divide are slower than adds and subtracts and so on, which is usually the case.
Then, what you want to do is give the priority to the slower unit.
Why? Well, because those instructions have been executing for
a while longer. So what's going to happen is those instructions are going to
have more dependencies probably waiting for them. Pretty much,
there are more instructions piled up to use these results. So it's, so
it's kind of like an age based thing, but instead of considering the age of each
instruction, in which case we would have to carry additional information here.
What we do is we simply give the priority to the smaller unit.
So this is a very common heuristic and that's usually what ends up being used.
If you really want to be kind of better than that, then you would, you know,
carry the age of the instruction in which case you can do age based thing, which
amounts to almost the same thing. Because usually these instruction's going to
be older here just because they're kind of slower to execute to begin with.
Or you do something slightly more advanced than that. But again, it's a very
common heuristic that we just used. Basically, the multiplication divide unit is
going to have priority in this case over the add and subtract unit.